bit of a late start here playin da Silva
from the u.s. to 25 form let's go for
Kings gambit and played this in a while
the declined with Bishop c5 maybe Knight
c3 is more precise ok really I don't
down know this line too much yeah this
is certainly a well-known line I never
really liked them the declined variation
here of the Kings gambit for black
always help that some of this is a
concession to allow right there 5 a
fourth but it certainly solid like it's
not suddenly not substantially worse
interesting if I just could take here I
can never take you five what is he doing
taking on a three this looks um taking
our frequent eggs looks very comfortable
check you know but this looks like a
very comfortable position now the
question is however how how should I
play Bishop g5 he probably needs to play
em should be seven
and that's also just clean g3 the other
interesting noises g-form 345 yep g45
and Bishop d too long castles I don't
need to Castle short necessarily Bishop
g5 was a good move as well but this is
some very direct play of course gain
gain spatium okay I'm always attacking
f7 so he cannot easily play let's say
quits his have no castles aha he's
trying to get the night to deform yep
but Queen g3 for instance and I no no no
come here I'd like to of course prevent
him from castling long if possible maybe
it's not possible to do that
hmm
Quincy seven long castles is hard to
prevent
maybe I can go for quick age 6 cm
and if he plays h6 himself okay I would
have at 92 g 3 and so on yeah and here i
thought one must be careful 92 g5 yep
directly opening up new position is this
this is threaten and Queen c3 is also
possible threat let's move it but this
is threatening a discovery now with
night a form
night a for Bishop before wait wait
would it not let's check this night a
form because queen bee five that's just
see form maybe see for queen bee 395
Quincy to check hmm yeah it doesn't seem
to work for him ok let's let's do that
first him it's no check
hmm
night in for this it should be form c3
night p 3 ever should before okay let's
do that maybe he takes on e2 and allows
me to check and win the queen but okay
you probably won't do that i'd like to
get his night exchanged here if it plays
a queen move i just take before and then
oops then i'm going to play against this
week f pawn this is the IDM
yeah maybe I can use g7 as a possible
entry point for look especially it's got
a bit of a passive position man and it
doesn't really have any big counter play
my king is quite secure intending look
g4g 70 not so sure what we should be six
is doing
I couldn't go look to g1 because of the
bishop him
okay if I take it green g7 mmm it's not
not directly winning but it's a very
good position he cannot take it this
pawn would be too dangerous and rock d 7
what is he playing look t 7 i'll just go
queen of six hard for him to to keep
keep us material together
43 seconds this is the main issue i
think bishops III attacking the upon a
good idea get the king of the plane
check yeah it can give this check but
getting this pawn
34 seconds yeah I need to be good but at
least he's taking a bit of time himself
so he's not just strictly trying to win
on time or something
check
yeah the pawns in the center should
should decide really try morning enough
to promote check check check check check
check
check game drawn ah he's got one second
left one second left and i'm not quite
sure what to it took I was some 2
seconds back here yeah okay whatever
it's a little shame but really should
have managed 22 seconds is plenty here
but yeah it's it's it's two queens
against sarouk with four seconds on the
clock yeah it's just it's a bit of bad
technique but okay two seconds and the
Queen Queen Queen he s much quicker
Quincy to on yeah okay it was a pretty
good game actually I think this was
another rather nicely played I always
kept an advantage here with the pawn
structure maybe had something even even
quicker around here this is this
possible but when is the win what what
more can you hope for Queen age 8 is
actually even stronger okay but I always
kept kept the winning edge right to the
end but yeah 0 second sis not enough
okay thanks for watching